[Musik]
ich bin banzer kommunalfahrzeug 935
mittel die aufgaben eines panzer
komponenten science die gruppe zu führen
sowie den schützenpanzer ulan im gepäck
zu hören
ich sagte meine fahrer wo er hinfahren
muss und verteile gegebenenfalls befehle
an die infanterie lustig zu machen habe
ich bleibe am schützenplatz und halte
verbindung 20
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin recht schützen schützenpanzer
land aufgaben gehören das bedienen der
kanone das bedienen der erwartung geräte
und unterstützendes genannten
durchschießen ist das highlight von
jedem recht schützen
da man die fracht vom panzer zum ersten
sieg
[Musik]
nach dem absitzen der infanterie
unterstützen wir sie beim vorgehen und
bleiben im ständigen funkkontakt
ich bin im fantrikot land in panik
rennen die partie des 31
die aufgaben eines infanterie rekruten
komponente sind eine gruppe zu führen
die aus sechs personen besteht
in verbindung mit einem schützenpanzer
[Musik]
wichtig dabei ist die verbindung zu dem
panzer
und die verbindung unseren anderen
[Musik]